jean-pierre colombiès bonjour merci
d'être heure joue en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors juste avant cette
manifestation le préfet de police de
paris appellent dans une lettre les
forces de l'ordre sous son autorité à
tenir je cite la ligne républicaine
jusqu'au bout qu'est ce que vous
comprenez derrière ces mots je sais pas
si vous avez lu la lettre dans son
intégralité mais c'est un morceau de
bravoure littéraire j'avoue que j'ai
écarquillé les yeux pour me demandant si
je si je lisais bien ce qui était écrit
parce que dans cette lettre
effectivement il rappelle la ligne
républicaine un petit peu comme si on
était déjà sur une ligne de front
toujours dans l'esprit du discours
guerrier qu'on nous assène depuis depuis
presque un an qu'ils étaient totalement
inadaptée mais ce qui m'inquiète moi
c'est qu'aussi dans ce courrier il fait
le rappel entre la police d'aujourd'hui
et celle d'il ya soixante seize ans en
faisant référence très probablement à la
révolte des policiers dans la cour du 19
août de la préfecture de police et
s'inscrivant dans la lutte contre la
barbarie
c'est exactement les termes qui
l'emploie dans son courrier donc est ce
que monsieur le préfet à 6000 encore la
population française aux barbares qui
viendraient agressé la république et par
répercussion la police
c'est une question qu'il faudrait
peut-être dû poser parce que là pour le
coup on serait dans une démagogie
sémantique mais totalement
disproportionnée bon il faudrait avoir
plus de temps pour elle pour évoquer ce
qui est en train de se passer mais je
vais essayer d'être synthétique mais ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui sur accor on
assiste aujourd'hui ces dérapages cette
violence mais c'est une violence de
société jacques emmanuel macron découvre
avec horreur que la police ne dérape
il est un petit peu dans la posture du
de l'arroseur arrosé
parce que c'est quand même sous son
autorité avec ses instructions qui ont
été déclinées au niveau du ministère de
l'intérieur et des préfectures diverses
et variées que la répression des
manifestations a pris une tournure
particulièrement nouvelle dans notre
pays parce que avant cela la gestion des
mouvements des maintien de l'ordre était
tout autre donc si aujourd'hui on se
plaint qu'une police dérape encore
eût-il fallu qu'on ne fasse pas tout ce
qu'il fallait pour qu'elle dérape
alors justement cet après midi comment
les forces de l'ordre ont intérêt à agir
selon vous on le sait vous le rappeliez
il ya aujourd'hui les méthodes de
c'est un ordre qui suscite le débat
pourrait tout à fait honnête j'aimerais
pas être à la place ni des hommes qui
sont sur le terrain ni de la hiérarchie
intermédiaire qui va les commandes et
parce qu'il est évident que il y a un
trouble particulier dans les
instructions qui leur sont données
puisque rappelez vous le préfet de
police tué m'avait dit qu'on entrait
dans une dynamique de contact qu'il
fallait le contacte donc il fallait pas
hésiter à faire mal c'est ça que ça veut
dire enfin vous faut arrêter de tourner
autour du pot
quand on vous dit des forces de police
aller au contact n'hésitez pas à
utiliser la force strictement nécessaire
voire au delà faut pas s'étonner après
qu'on ait des images et des images
catastrophiques comme on a l'habitude de
les voir
et puis vous avez aussi la tentation
évidente est logique d'une tentative de
récupération politique qui d'ailleurs
récupération politique c'est peut-être
bien inspiré d'avoir elle aussi une
ligne philosophique clair et net
parce que vous savez vous échappera pas
que les manifestations prennent
quasiment systématiquement une tournure
violente ces derniers temps mais tout
simplement parce que la population
probablement peut-être c'est une
interrogation qu'on peut avoir
ne trouve plus auprès des relais
politiques traditionnels conventionnelle
l'appui qu'elle ne mériterait peut-être
d'avoir si il n'ya pour la population
que la rue pour s'exprimer avec le
soutien d'associations diverses et
variées et pas toujours pas toujours je
dirais identifiables on en est on en est
à une situation totalement incontrôlée
la population n'a plus auprès des partis
politiques classiques comme elle l'avait
autrefois le soutien leur père et
l'appui dont elle aurait besoin
aujourd'hui donc on assiste
effectivement des débordements de tous
les côtés parce que c'est vrai qu'on a
d'un côté
violence qu'on a pu voir un film et des
forces de l'ordre en tout cas les
contacts et puis de l'autre cette vidéo
montrant michel est clair se faire taper
par des policiers est là le président de
la république
il a réagi en se disant très choquée
pourquoi il réagit maintenant sur cette
vidéo est finalement on l'a pas attendu
lors des précédentes nombreuses alertes
notamment à lors des manifestations des
gilets jaunes
oui non mais ça ça pose sa pose
clairement la question du timing et de
l'appréciation qu'on a qu'on appuie sa
vie tout ça je pense que clairement la
situation leur échappe échappe à tout le
monde
on s'est peut-être imaginer qu'après la
crise de la crise des gilets jaunes on
aller gentiment juillet ce qui s'était
passé
enfin ces petits ce dg john faut le
rappeler quand même elle a duré aussi
longtemps parce que le pouvoir voulait
qu'elle dure il suffisait c'est pas moi
qui le dis d'ailleurs à tous les
observateurs politiques l'ont fait
remarquer à l'époque il aurait fallu
qu'il y ait un geste significatif de la
part du pouvoir
une temporisation dans la dans le cadre
de l'application des mesures pour que
cette crise jaune
cette crise des gilets jaunes pardon ne
dure pas neuf mois quasi un mois
quasiment un an mais ne dure que
quelques semaines et qu'on s'assoit
autour d'une table et que enfin les
discussions politiques aient lieu et
d'ailleurs je précise quand même que au
travers des interventions que j'ai pu
avoir et que l'association et pmi a pu
avoir si ce qu'on a eu de cesse de
répéter qu'il ne fallait qu'il fallait
cesser impérativement l'opposition de
mettre en opposition à la police et à la
citoyenneté pour éviter justement que
nous on en arrive aujourd'hui à cette
situation aberrante d'une véritable
haine d'une fraction de la population
contre la police et donc de fait en
retour en miroir d'une radicalisation
des méthodes de la police et d'une
crispation absolue on n'a jamais connu
ça je dirais on n'a jamais connu une
telle une telle haine une tête
crispation de tels débordements et une
telle défiance aujourd'hui de la
population vis-à-vis de la police c'est
très grave ce qui se passe est très
grave
mais ne perdons pas de vue que c'était
plus ou moins voulu en tout cas que
c'était toléré
on a laissé faire le gouvernement sous
l'autorité de monsieur macron a laissé
faire cette situation à l'époque avec
christophe castaner aujourd'hui avec
gérald darmanin qui ont beau jeu de
dénoncer les dérives les excès et les
bavures ans pour ça que pour rechercher
les bavures policières quand l oms
quand elles ont lieu mais encore eût-il
fallu que je dirais l'ambiance
philosophico-politique nahd ne crée pas
ce complexe
merci mme ogou jean-pierre colombiès
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes porte parole de l'ue pénis et
l'union des policiers nationaux
indépendants